[Music]
so
uh hi i'm jacqueline nolis i'm a data
scientist i'm joined here today by
heather nolis a machine learning
engineer from t-mobile
and this talk is about how we did
something we're really
we're so excited about and it's how we
got our working in our
production environments so what does it
mean to put something into production we
heard about that a little bit already
during the keynotes
um but we think about it like this you
know with data science there's like two
types of data science
there's a type analysis where you you're
trying to figure out an idea
do an exploration you know figure out
something and your
deliverable is an idea and then there's
the building type where you
you make a machine learning model and
you want to run it you want to run it
over and over like if you're designing a
product recommendation engine
for a website and so at t-mobile
we really define putting code into
production as making it so that
customers can interact with it
and this morning we heard about you know
making dashboards that many users can
use at once maybe 20.
well we have 70 million customers and we
just merged with sprint who has another
60 million customers so we have
lots and lots of people and when we're
talking about machine learning
we're really talking about making
machine learning models that all of
those people can use
hopefully not all at once but all of
them could use
and so the project was called ai at
t-mobile so
t-mobile has been doing data science for
many years and we have lots of people
who are very good at things like
that exploration building churn models
on our customers you know that sort of
reporting work
but we didn't have very much of putting
machine learning models
that we developed into production
environments so our customers can use
them
so this project was to actually take
machine learning and get it in front of
our customers in a way that really
improves the customer experience and we
i say that because t-mobile has a really
big
big deal about being the uncarrier so
we're not going to make you have to go
deal with chat bots and have bad
experiences we want things to be
pleasant for our customers
so our first scope was customer care
messaging
so right now today you can go on your
phone and you can text t-mobile and you
can say something like
i don't have you know my coverage is bad
and a human being
at a desk will respond back to you and
help you try and diagnose your problem
and so we can do that through text
message we can do that through facebook
messenger
you can slide into t-mobile's dms and
send a message and a human being will
respond back to you or use our in-app
messaging
so we have all of this text data we have
all of this stuff that's right for
natural language processing
and our objective was let's get some
machine learning around that that makes
things better for the customer
so our first particular use case
was consider you know our customers they
talk in all sorts of weird ways
so suppose we had one particular
customer come to us and say this high
bill
shall not pass which is an utterance
we've never seen before
and you know we have the goal if we have
a an agent at a computer who's
responding to these messages and maybe
has like eight conversations going on at
once
we have the goal to try and prep them
that like oh it'd be really helpful
if that agent when they started the
conversation already knew the status of
the customer's bill
and so what is our method well we're
going to build a classification engine
with machine learning
so in this case this high bill shall not
pass would be classified as a bill
breakdown message
and further we can improve that by
actually using customer data so if we
know
something about this customer like if we
know um their recent account activity
their current signal strength their bill
status like radiates overdue
that may change what we want to show the
agent so you can imagine if a customer
just got their account suspended
like 20 minutes ago and they come to
t-mobile and they say hi
well we probably know what they're
talking about um so we can use that data
to help inform our machine learning
prediction
so how do we create the models in r well
our workflow was like this one we would
start by using our markdown for
exploratory analysis
so we would take those many
conversations that we have between
customers and agents
and we'd try and build build an
understanding of what happens on them
what are the
things people kind of talk about and
then once we get a better idea we would
build a machine learning model
in r and then we'd save those models to
flat files
and in particular we would do the model
building with our markdown so that we
could actually have a log of exactly how
it was built what data went in how well
the
fit went and then we save all of that
and then before we even get to actually
like deploying or anything
we need to get the business people to be
excited about this so we show our model
off with a shiny demo
so after we do the exploratory analysis
you know we would start building a model
in our models we ended up building
neural networks using keras so keras is
a really really cool r package from our
studio that lets you very easily
build deep learning models and so for us
we ended up using a convolutional neural
network which is a particular type of
neural network to do the text parsing
and understand what was the topic going
on in the text
but we also had to bring in all those
other data types too like what's the
order status
or you know is there a account currently
suspended and so we had more traditional
neural networks
parse that data and then we put that all
together with one file neural network
that outputs which classification so in
this case we would train
would train a neural network that would
learn that unlock my phone
with a recent order uh that has an 80
chance of being categorized and
unlocked so we built this networks and
we were pretty excited about them
but we have these problems because we'd
go into meetings with business people
and be like guys we're having
look at these roc curves our a you know
like 80.8 and i like
whatever and so like we had one meeting
with some business people and like 10
minutes before we're like
let's just throw it in a shiny demo and
let's change the game
the fact that we actually had shiny
demos where a business person could type
in
i want to unlock my phone and actually
watch that i would give classified as
unlock
like this got us and i'm not
exaggerating millions of dollars of
funding
multiple people added to our team and
it's because we could take this show it
to a business person who showed it to
the director who showed it to the vp
who eventually we ended up showing this
stuff to the cio all because we had a
really nice shiny demo
um that was built around our models um
and so if you look this doesn't look
quite like a normal
it really didn't look normal that
doesn't look like quite a normal shiny
demo
and it's because we decided to spend an
extra day using um
i'm going to give this a little wiggle
let's see if that okay
we spent an extra day making the html
look nicer
and that really again gave us a really
polished professional view
um so i'm a data scientist and i'm very
comfortable doing all the things i just
showed
but putting things in production
deployments when i started this project
a lot of that stuff was new for me but
thankfully our team had
some machine learning engineers to help
okay
am i on hello can anybody hear me there
we go
okay so when it came time to put our
models in production i was handed these
r files and i was a java developer
and i was like i really don't know what
to do with this or how to get it
in a place that can interface with our
70 plus million customers
and so every single person had told our
team if you want to do
machine learning in production you have
to use python
but i just handled a really cool r
project so i was like
hiring data scientists to redo all this
work in python and redo an analysis
seems
silly um since the model's already built
and it's very good and the business
people really like it
i could convert it to python and then
put it in production but
that seems silly um so i was like what
if we just
do it all in our and what if we take out
this double work that people
assume that you have or you have to
rewrite things for 70 million people
using python um so yeah the radical idea
here was what if we treat r like a real
programming language
because it is a programming language um
and so how things work on our team is we
have all of our stuff in repositories as
soon as you make
a commit and so this is the way any of
our java or node projects would work
as soon as you make a commit to a
repository some software called jenkins
builds it up into its final project
marathon
it's kind of like off-brand kubernetes
uh orchestrates the container
development and mazes hosts and
replicates those containers for you
so we have a really nice system in place
for java projects where you can just
make a commit and then instantly
something's in production and it's
facing with your customers
so i was like well let's make r do that
and avoid this whole python trip
entirely
and so the first thing that we had to do
is we had to convert
our r models into an api and so what an
api is
is right now if i was to go on my phone
and type weather.com
it returns back some website for me and
that's an api it's just a way of using
the internet
to send a message i want to go to
weather.com and get some information
back here's the entire website that's
weather.com
you can also use it with model input and
output so we send we want you to predict
how long
this stem length is send it to the model
via an api and then it comes back
okay i have a prediction for you so it's
very very easy
so once you have a rest controller which
defines all the little slashes that you
would put on your website url
um you just start plumber on your r
model and then now you can go
into your browser and type in something
and immediately get information from our
model back despite not being close to it
which is really cool and that's how all
of our services talk to each other in
engineering is via api calls so this way
we can have java talking to python
talking to r
it all makes sense because it all uses
the internet
and then the way that we package
everything up on our team is with
containers and so
what containers are is if i was to go to
best buy right now and buy
a laptop and i really wanted to put
jaclyn's model on it
i would have to go home i would sit down
i would install i don't know
my internet and i would install outlook
and then i would install our studio and
then all of the packages needed for our
studio
and it gets quite cumbersome to set up
the machine and then of course i'm using
a more recent version of the package
than she was using so her model still
won't run even though she emailed me and
i downloaded it
and so what docker is essentially is
just a way to write down all of those
instructions so that way they're
repeatable
forever so that way any time a new
virtual machine is spun up
a little container on it can just repeat
those docker images and they have the
exact same thing that i was looking at
when i was on my laptop or the same
thing jaclyn was looking at when she was
on her laptop
so i can then take my code to someone
who doesn't have r
installed on their computer and if they
have docker it will run on their machine
and so the first problem that we
actually had is i have this container
we used a rocker-based image rocker is a
company that makes these
are i guess it's an organization that
makes these r based docker images so you
can just kind of copy the work that
they've done
and start from there and the first thing
is so i have r in a docker image and i
have jaclyn's model but
the big problem is that our keras
actually requires python
so you have to call python on the end so
we're like okay we have this
docker image that contains r it contains
our studio it contains our models so
okay let's
put in the actual python that's required
to make this run so okay we finally get
python installed
everything should be good but it's not
because plumber doesn't support https
and we're a big enterprise and so we
have to have really secure connections
between stuff so http was not sufficient
so inside of our docker container okay
we'll add an apache 2 server that sits
in the same container as our r code and
all it does is take https request
converts them to http
does the model processing and then
passes it back through so okay so now we
have
we have r and we have the model and we
have python and we have this apache 2
server and so
it's getting quite hefty and that was
actually the next trouble that we ran
into we went we deployed it it went
through our python it went out
perfect but it was nearly five gigs in
size by the time that you get
all the dependencies and everything that
you need and so this is a quick
breakdown
of what our container actually looked
like so if you look
the bulk of the container ends up being
python um
and our devops team was like you guys
can't keep running
five gig containers you've taken down
entire t-mobile clusters
like huge problems are occurring because
you're throwing this out there so you
say
okay we'll do some work and so um we
switched the full version of anaconda
python which is what tensorflow requires
to miniconda
we removed our studio from the docker
image and then we spent a lot of time
removing all these unnecessary linux and
r
and python libraries to get the
container size small enough that devops
would say okay
we're totally fine with you using r now
because you've made it small enough it
contains all of our security
requirements it contains everything it
needs to run it looks good to go
and we did it so we deployed a model in
our the first t-mobile's first customer
facing deep learning model and it was
all completely written
in r so it's an r native api it has
tensorflow
it's super super small and it's just as
secure as everybody wants it to be and
is required
so really cool
but we learned a lot of stuff in doing
this and so
i think that the first thing that we
learned is you know people came to us in
the beginning and said
you have to write this in python we
won't support you doing an r
but we tested our apis at 50 times to
mobile's maximum load and r performed
just fine
so for us our using rn plumber was at
very close parity performance wise with
python and flask
and then r was really good for us to do
the quick data exploration that got us
the idea to build this model in the
first place
and then the shiny demos are what really
really sold our project and there's not
really an equivalent for
python you can't just quickly throw a
few lines of code and take it to a
business person and have it passed
around like that
and most importantly language was never
the fail point for our project
it was always security concerns that the
container being too big or python being
giant or some dependency projects but it
was never
r that was the reason that we were
struggling at any point
and the next thing we learned is that
it's really really critical to work in
a flat team so traditionally how this
works is data scientists they build the
model and they'll send it over to the
engineers
the engineers rewrite in python they
make it into something else and then
they'll deliver it to the business but
the business wants it a little bit
different so it goes back to the data
scientist
and we stopped that chain of telephone
and we're like what if we all just sit
together
so our team was literally two machine
learning engineers three data scientists
a java engineer
and then our business person all
together at the same table every single
day
so that way if the machine learning
engineers can be developing the api and
then the data scientists find something
new they want to do and you can just
talk to each other instead of waiting
two months until you get a finished
product and then trying to iterate on
that
so it made it a very very very agile
structure
so with all that work it was a lot of
work
we were very excited about fun work um
where are we today
well first off your mic's not on oh
yeah okay cool great um
the first thing is we have r in
production right now in a way that any
iphone user
in the audience right now you guys can
hit our code make our code run
which is i don't know i never thought
there'd be that day never mind i was
part of that day
um so in particular there's a product
called apple business chat
so about a year ago apple released this
way for companies to actually use
imessage
so if you search for t-mobile on your
iphone you can start a chat with
with t-mobile and it's like a nicely
colored branded box
but t-mobile doesn't get to know your
telephone number all they know is that
you're an anonymous person
and so the first thing t-mobile used to
do was ask you hey are you a customer or
not
because they needed to know if they
wanted to write you to customer carriers
or sales
and so we'd ask the customer and get a
yes or no back and to us this was
ridiculous
right if someone says why is my bill so
high of course they should go to
customer if someone says i want to
switch to t-mobile they should not go to
customer
um and so we built a machine learning
model around that
and so now every time someone an
imessage starts a new conversation
it send it to the our machine learning
model if the our machine learning model
is confident they're a customer or
confident they're not then they don't
see this picker at all
if we kind of get unsure if they just
say hi then they would still get the
picker like gold so
we've actually used machine learning and
ai to make the customer experience
more streamlined rather than to do an
annoying chatbot kind of like please say
unlock you know
um so we're really proud of that um
and also you can have some of this work
too so we took a lot of what we've done
and we really packaged it up and made it
open source
so we've written several blog posts on
how to get started with plumber
docker and our um our actual code and
then we created a repository that is a
full docker container that uses r
running a tensorflow neural network um
that you can you can install windows r
you can download this and run it and it
just works
um the neural network we used as our
sample data
generates uh pet names so it's a lot of
fun
i recommend you trying it out um but
this is really something that
you know i highly if you're interested
in how to work i encourage highly
encourage you just to look at it because
you know you may learn a couple things
that might make it easier and the
things that we had to learn ourselves
over a lot of time
um so thank you so much the materials
from this are all located at nolaslc.com
rstudio19 the blog post the github
repository these slides um so that's
really useful
our twitter handles are up there we love
being tweeted at um
and thank you so much and i'd like to
also just thank you know heather and i
are here
um uh james allison our product person
is in the audience and we are so many
other
t-mobile people who really helped with
this project too so we like to do a lot
of talking but it was not just us
we did this project and also we could
talk about this literally all day we
were like how can we
condense it down into just 20 minutes um
and then also we are hiring so if you
think that what we're doing sounds
really cool we need really good data
scientists we prefer our users obviously
and so this seems like a really great
place to kind of announce that and you
can hit us up on
twitter whatever you feel like
[Applause]
great thank you heather and jacqueline
um we've got time for a couple of
questions i think we have some
microphones we can toss around
on that in the back so yeah it looks
like we've got some people so if you
have questions
raise your hand i'll try to point those
out so that we can have a microphone
right over there
hi hello okay um i was just curious that
you said you
showed business people shiny apps to
demo your model do you have like an area
where you just
deploy those kind of shiny apps for
projects yeah so our shiny projects
actually go through the same pipeline
that i just showed you and so we have
one single container right now that
contains all of our different
shiny apps and we have it up so that way
any time that james needs to go take
this to a business person and show
something that we built off the link is
up and always ready for
him to do that yeah we i would say we
are gonna switch to having a
docker container that has each app in it
separately because we've run into
trouble where like we've updated one app
and it's broken other so yeah going
forward and switching to one container
for each
but yeah
is that me get one over there yep um
because this
specific instance is a keras model um
that isn't necessarily specific to our
python do you need our python
at all is it because of like the api
wrapper or text pre-processing
like so i think that from from my
perspective it was that
i was handed a model nr why would i
rebuild that
right like it's it already exists and so
the exploration was done in our and so
that's why we decided to support our
natives yeah
and so in particular like you do you
know with us we first take the
conversation and then we remove the
weird characters and then we do this and
then we feed it to the model and you
know some of our engineers are like wow
we could technically run tensorflow in
java
but then we'd have to figure out what to
do with all those steps and it's like
well we'd have to keep them in our
anyway so
and so yeah so i think that normally the
argument that people put forth is like
oh well it's more scalable and we
support java and it's like
we just used all the java tools that
exist and did it in r and it worked just
fine and then you
eliminate the double work
okay i have a question for your for your
neural network
so based on application looks to me it's
a
it's like a natural language processing
so it should be the sequence model but
you mentioned about the convolutionary
neural network can you give me some
explanation here yeah so we tried
actually started with a recurrent neural
network
and we found that the recurrent neural
network did not perform as well as a
convolutional neural network
our suspicion is because of the
classification usually someone says bill
so
high and like those three words it
doesn't matter what's all around it
um so that's our suspicion for why a
convolutional neural network works
slightly better
but we were actually surprised at how
shallow our
the optimal networks ended up being like
we were expected to have like five
layers and
recurrence but it's like it's really
it's like one convolutional layer
one or two um dense layers and then
that's the whole network
you spoke about uh making your app
secure
can you speak a bit about that like
two-factor authentication and
how you're able to achieve that using r
yeah so all of our stuff right now is
accessed from
within our network so we don't have to
do an apogee authentication but if we
did an apogee authentication it would be
very simple we would just make the
relative
api calls one thing that we did do is
that all of our messages have to be
passed encrypted
and so we used a um there's a library
that's sodium that's really good in
encryption and then you can decrypt in
java so we were being passed
things from java that we then had to
decrypt and then re-encrypt in r
and so we use that all using the sodium
library to do that which is aes256
encryption so it's pretty secure
you